[Music]
what
just
[Music]
C
for
[Music]
yeah
thank
[Music]
you
Christian
[Music]
pi
is it really is it with
[Music]
an over
can swipe to get in the door
[Music]
that's hello
everybody I've said it before but I
think it's so funny how it kind of just
naturally gets quiet as the time goes
down but I don't know if it's cuz I
walked up here but we'll just go with it
um welcome everyone my name is miam if I
haven't met you all I think I have the
smaller crowd tonight but that's all
good um you all have these papers on
your seats they're kind of strewn across
all these seats and if you don't know
this is unfortunately yet fortunately
our last weekend here in this space um
we've loved being here but we're U
moving somewhere that has a bit more
room for us as we're growing and needing
more room so this is a map and kind of
directions to get there or you could be
like me and just type in the address in
your phone and follow it that way so um
feel free to take this take a picture of
it um but next week we will be at that
new
facility so um again if you're needing
any of the information on how to get
there go ahead and use that um maps are
available in the the lobby or there's a
QR code you can scan that and get the
information that way um in two weeks for
Super Bowl Sunday we know that a lot of
y'all might skip church to to watch
Super Bowl but and myself included I'm
guilty but we will have our service an
hour earlier so at 400 PM instead of
5:00 p.m. so if you show up at 5:00 p.m.
we're going to be wrapping things up so
make sure you come an hour earlier if
you're planning to come um to church on
February the 11th that's two weeks from
tonight um make sure again because this
is going to be our last night here at
this facility make sure that you go in
the foyer there's going to be a banner
um just sign that or you know write a
little note your U gratitude you know
for um Denise and the team that has let
us use this facility for so long so uh
you can find that after the service um
it's been four years or so I believe
that we've been in here since Co
um so yeah we're just very grateful uh
to have been able to use this space um
before we get into prayer uh I was I was
thinking um has anyone seen The Flash
the TV
show
no okay okay big superhero nerd here if
you know anything about me I love
superheroes and I've already watched it
but I like to go to the gym every day
and just put on kind of like a Mindless
show in the background with my
headphones and I'm rewatching The Flash
um huge flash fan I've got him tattooed
on my leg and everything and uh Big Nerd
but um people always ask me why do you
like him like there's so many other
superheroes like what is it about the
Flash and I've thought about it and um
two things about him number one came
from kind of like an ugly background
right terrible Terri terrible upbringing
some bad things happen yet he decided to
do good in his adult life to still help
people and I I got thinking even deeper
people are like why do you have the
flash on your leg well number one I like
him number two there's an idea a deeper
meaning behind that tattoo for me as in
I have always felt that I needed to wear
a mask and I'm not talking because of Co
I've always felt that I needed to wear a
mask growing up and be someone that I
wasn't and so after I came out I was
like I'm going to get a tattoo of The
Flash with his mask on
because the mask has always comforted me
it's always been something I could hide
behind but I don't need that anymore and
kind of metaphorically it's like I've
got the flash on my leg and he's wearing
the mask for me now I don't I'm good I'm
in a place in life I'm in a church that
I can be free to be who I am feel free
to be who I am and I hope that you all
feel that while walking into this um not
even this building just this space with
these people that you feel free to take
off whatever mask you have on and you
know that you are welcome here just the
way that you are I'm going to lead us in
a little bit of a prayer before we go
into
worship God thank you so much for us um
all the people that have made it here
safely and those watching online and US
Gathering here together we're so so
grateful for this space that we have
been able to grow in and that we have
you know the opportunity to go somewhere
else that's going to
allow more and more people to
gather to gather to worship you and
gather as a
family and just feel safe and seen and
heard I pray that you continue to to
bless this church to bless this building
to bless everyone that's been a part of
the table growing over the last four
years and I pray that we all enjoy the
message tonight and that you use
Brett to speak to us and that again you
just make this a place of happiness and
gratefulness that we have been able to
gather here for so long it's in Jesus
name I pray
amen you like to stand up and join us in
music y'all one last week in this space
I'm I'm very honored to be a part of the
music team today um with our last time
here so we have Caleb over here and
Maggie Gary's on guitar
um I'm just so grateful to see each and
every one of you here and I hope that
our time here in this building has been
meaningful to you and special and I just
want to say that as we progress and move
forward um I pray that we would be able
to do that with unity and really a sense
of this isn't the end of something only
but there is a new chapter as we turn
the page so Denise thank you again um
and let's sing
together
keep if you lost and you
know go and figure out why take a trip
to your dark side go on and have a good
Pride cuz we're all
lonely yeah we're all
lonely
together I want to see your
sadness I want to share your sins I want
to bleed your blood and I want to be let
in don't you
just don't we all just want to be
together leave what's
Heaven what
[Music]
heav what's heavy
behind
leave what's
heaven what's
[Music]
behind if your face is
down take a look
around do your fingers move do your
lungs in play are you tired are you
weary of the Hidden hate you've been
[Applause]
holding did you lose that love or have
you never had it are you feeling sad cuz
you did a bad thing
what's
heav what's heav
behind
leave what's
heavy what's heav
behind
are you feeling brother are you feeling
fearful
sister the only way to lose that fearful
feeling repl it with love that's
he
are you feeling fearful brother are you
feeling fearful
[Music]
[Applause]
sister what's
heavy what's heavy
behind what's
heavy what's heavy behind
[Music]
again what heavy
behind one more
time what's
heavy what's heavy
behind all right kiddos thank you for
holding down the Clapping there you guys
are dismissed we've got any kids that
are first grade and younger over here to
your right through these doors and
Britney Johnson along with a couple of
our teens Eve Tilford El Johnson are
serving over there thank you guys so
much and uh Kelly Tilford and Julie
Livingston are over here with any kids
that you have that might be second grade
and up through sixth grade so feel free
to make y'all's ways over to your
classrooms and have fun in there and um
as for us in here we're so glad you're
with us and we like to take a moment at
the beginning of each of our services to
pause and pray together and bring
whatever we brought into the room the
way I heard someone say it once is If
This Were an airplane what baggage are
you holding with you and what are you
bringing on this trip because we're all
in here together and we share this space
and our lives bleed over into each other
more than we could ever imagine so we
want to give a moment to acknowledge
what's in the room and to lift it up
before God and lay it before him and let
go of some of our own worry and control
and anxiety so if you would join us in
the prayers of the people we're going to
do that on a communal and a global level
as well as a personal level so we will
leave space for you to mention anything
that's on your heart personally as well
but first let's just pray these words
together that are on the
screen
for this city of saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them and we pray to you for the
Good Earth that you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it
we pray to you for the old and the sick
for the Widow and orphan for the injured
and suffering we pray to you for the
poor and the oppressed the unemployed
and destitute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them
we pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss
loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to
you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
[Music]
you
your
[Music]
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
amen s this Christ is Christ is my firm
foundation The Rock on which I
stand everything around me
Shen I've never been more glad cuz I put
my faith in
Jesus he's never let me down faithful
through
generations so why would he fail
now he
w
he
W I've got the joy in
chaos I've got peace that makes no sense
so I won't be going
under I'm not held by My Own Strength I
built my life on
Jesus and he's never Liv let me down
he's faithful in every
season so why would he fail
now he
[Music]
W he
won't he won't
fail he won't
fail he
won he
[Music]
wanton he won't
fail he won't
fail he
W came wind blue my house was built
built on
you I'm safe with you I'm going to make
it through sing rain came rain came
winds BL my house was built on
you and I am safe with you I'm going to
make it through I'm going to he I'm
going to make it
through cuz I'm standing strong on
you yes I'm going to make it
through cuz my house was built on you
Christ is my firm
foundation The Rock on which I
stand everything around me is
Shen I've never been more glad I put my
faith in
Jesus he's never let me down faithful
through
generations so I would he up now he
w
he
won't he won't
[Music]
fail he won't
fail he
W he
W he won't
fail he won't fail
he
W he
[Music]
w
C up in your
presence I just want to S here at your
feet I'm caught up in this
holy
moment and I never want to
[Music]
leave
oh I'm not here for
blessings Jesus you don't know
me
anything more than
anything that you can
do I just one
you I just want
you nothing
else nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want
you nothing
else nothing
else nothing else will
do I'm going to be your
[Applause]
presence I just want to S here at your
feet I'm caugh up in this
ho
M I never want to
[Music]
leave I'm not here for bless
Jesus you don't know
me
anything more than
anything that you can
do I just want
you I just want you I just want
you nothing
nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want
you nothing
else nothing
else nothing else will
do
I'm C up in your
presence oh my just want to sit here at
your
feet I'm caught up in this
holy
moment I never want to
[Music]
leave Jesus you are our Strong
Tower
you are a
protection when we feel Under
Fire God you're the lifter of our heads
when we have lost
hope and when we become the worst
version of ourselves Lord You remind us
that we are
loved that we are
wanted that we are not
[Music]
alone we reenter ourselves on your truth
your goodness your
faithfulness your trustworthy love right
now
God and regardless of what systems or
structures or people may have hurt us
failed us let us
down
or the ways that we ourselves have
fallen
[Music]
short God we reenter on
you would you be all in
[Music]
all rightly order our desires
God that we could live as a people who
are satisfied inside of your
[Music]
love we give you this time in this
space may you be enthroned on our
thoughts and our praises and our words
in Jesus name we pray
amen you could be
seated all right all right
will Grace and peace it is so good to be
with you all my name is Brett and um
it's always a joy to to welcome you into
this space and uh like a few people of
reference I know it can take a lot of
courage to come through those doors um
especially those of you who are new uh
it's just yeah we all we all come here
with many stories you know lots of
everyone has a different story and for
some folks they're like super comfy um
in a church space and others are like oh
God here we go again so um that being
said I'm I'm really glad that that
you're here tonight I hope you feel that
sense of of uh welcome and um also those
join us online y'all have not forgotten
uh love you lots as well so um let's see
here we are um a few Sundays now in
where I'm kind of I'm jumping into the
season it's called Epiphany in the
church calendar um we've had some
one-off kind of stuff going on with you
know not stuff good things baptisms and
story Sunday and it was like all sorts
of good stuff to kick off the year um
but I'm wed to jump back in with the
church calendar there's something uh if
you've been around the table a while you
know we do different things sometimes we
join kind of the broader Church in uh
like really the global church as they uh
kind of go through certain Seasons you
know um Advent which leads up to
Christmas there's now Epiphany which
sort of follows Christmas um there's um
in a few months there'll be lint uh
which leads in Easter and you know those
kinds of rhythms and times other times
we'll like jump off we'll do just series
and topical type things um but we I do
see a lot of value though in kind of
joining in with the broader church maybe
I feel it's even especially important
for one a community like ours that can
at times feel at least in our social
context so kind of uh edged out in a
ways you know that um that to to say
like hey you know um even if you are not
for us we are for you you know and um
and even to recognize that there are
churches and communities um I think of
the United Methodist to uh the wonderful
Pleasant Valley United Methodist Church
which has let us be here for over four
years and um Reverend Denise Mason is
here tonight she leads that community
and and then the new space that we're
going to over there at first saxi um
with Reverend Holly bandal like right
there's communities that welcome us and
uh it's good to I think join in and um
not get too kind of Ed or feeling edged
out so um with that in mind we are in
this season of epiphany so you might
wonder like what is that you know what
is maybe you're not even you know
familiar with like Epiphany didn't know
that was a a thing um so if Advent kind
of prepares you for the coming of Christ
well Epiphany is like it's sort of a a
celebration um slash a kind of coming to
grips with okay what does this mean you
know so it's not so much a preparation
that's Advent like preparing in our
hearts for the Lord you know now um he's
here Christ is Among Us Christ is in the
world and so now we're we're so a lot of
the the text you'll see are kind of
moments of Revelation moments of God
speaking and the people are um wrestling
with um what that means for them in
their own lives um so that's kind of
what the the season of epiphany is all
about so with that in mind the title of
my message tonight um is it's a strange
one radios Bob Dylan in the heart of a
child
and uh our text is a story about a boy
named Samuel um who would grow up to be
one of the great um prophets in
Israelite history um you know this
because the stories about Samuel and the
book where're we're reading from is
first Samuel you know so it's like got
got a book in the Bible actually got two
so you know legit um so we pick up the
story there 1 Samuel um chapter 3 verse
1 it says this the boy Sam Samuel
ministered before the Lord under Eli in
those days the word of the Lord was rare
there were not many Visions one night
Eli whose eyes were becoming so weak
that he could hardly see was lying down
in his usual place the lamp of God had
not yet gone out and Samuel was lying
down in the house of the Lord where the
Ark of God was and the Lord called
Samuel Samuel answered here I am and he
ran to Eli and he said here I am you
called me but Eli said I did not call go
back and lie down so he went and lay
down again the Lord called
Samuel and Samuel got up and went to Eli
and said here I am you called me my son
Eli said I did not call go back and lie
down he's probably wondering why are you
keep waking me up bro yeah
um now Samuel did not yet did not yet
know know the Lord the word of the Lord
had not yet been revealed to him a third
time the Lord called Samuel and Samuel
got up and went to Eli and said here I
am you called me then Eli realized that
the Lord was calling the boy so Eli told
Samuel go and lie down and if he calls
you say Speak Lord for your servant is
listening so Samuel went and he lay down
in his place the Lord came out and stood
there calling as at other times Samuel
Samuel then Samuel said
speak for your servant is
listening it's one of the more I think
profound
stories and you'll notice it's a bit of
a a contrast
story so if you're familiar with kind of
the broader context um we'll get to this
a little bit later there's Eli who's
mentioned who is basically like the high
priest and then Samuel is not really
he's not yet an acting priest he's very
a Boy Child um but he'll be trained to
be that uh and then there's Eli's Sons
um we'll get to them later so right now
it's just Eli
and in in the story right there is
Samuel the child who hears and then
there's the other right there's the
adults um Eli who the text says he has
these kind of fading Powers um his eyes
it says are weak I wonder if not only
maybe is that just pure you know biology
he's getting older uh but I wonder if
that's sort of a a poetic nod to as
you'll kind of find out Eli's own um
kind of fading powers of
discernment uh to to hear the voice of
God that that there's kind of a yeah
maybe an illusion
to that um
so you've got yeah you've got kind of
Eli then there's Eli's dysfunctional
Sons um mentioned in the previous
chapter and you can kind of see why this
text would be read right during the
season of epiphany right it's this
moment God is
speaking uh and the people in the story
though um they are struggling to
hear right struggling to discern and so
the the kind of question um driving my
message tonight is why did they
struggle and why do we um not hopefully
in a kind of heavy-handed you know why
do we you know or even preachers are
like to use the word you a lot you know
um you you know um but but why do why do
we um struggle at times to to hear so
let me start by naming what it is
not so our challenge to hear The
Whispers of the spirit um I I don't
believe they're they're not rooted in a
lack of God
speaking now the thing is the opening
verse of the story so the second part of
verse one uh might seem to be kind of in
contradiction to this though I don't
think it is but but I do want to to
speak to that so you might have caught
it the second part of verse one in those
days the word of the Lord was rare there
were not many
visions and I think this is where
often we begin to interpret without even
realizing we're interpreting you know we
just think well I'll just read the Bible
but we all we don't just read it we we
interpret it you know we bring a lot to
the text I think this is where our own
image of God uh can kind of play out we
we talk often here at the table about
how are how who do we understand the god
revealed in Jesus Christ to be what's
the image operating there is it um sort
of one of love and faithfulness and
goodness or is is it a kind of different
image you know is God sort of uh
judgmental and stingy and slightly angry
or maybe more than slightly and kind of
depending you know on the image of God
we have that we bring to the story right
we kind of hear this in every way so I
could imagine if we had a more kind of
um harsh image of God we might hear that
you know that opening of verse one oh in
those days the word of the Lord was rare
and we would say see I told you this is
classic God classic like everyone's like
Lord please speak we hunger for your
word and God's like
no you know just
uhuh and it's just a classic just
holding out on people holding out wi
withdrawing his word withholding his
guidance withholding his
vision and uh I wonder I wonder if
that's just a complete misreading
um because actually what you see as I've
kind of already alluded to in the the
previous chapters which just for the
sake of time um I'll recap but we won't
read it what you see is we don't know
about like the whole you know broader
Israelite Community we can say at least
at the kind of religious institutional
level it's a hot
mess it's it's bad so here's a little
bit of the background you have Eli um
who in the story story you know he he
doesn't come across like terrible I mean
even with Samuel you can see a certain
sensitivity he's quite patient I think
you um but so basically the the real
problem comes with Eli's Sons so if Eli
is sort of the high priest but he's so
elderly now he's not really you know
can't do it being a priest back then was
like a very physical job it was about
sacrifices you know it's like picking up
like meat and putting it in a kettle I
mean it was like real physical type
stuff so um he's not doing that so his
he had two sons and they were I mean
dysfunctional is putting it too nicely
um there a there the text mentions that
they're stealing from the
sacrifices um taking more for themselves
than they should have according to kind
of the the laws and ordinances um but
second there's this sort of um it says
that that they're having um sexual
encounters with women
around uh kind of around the kind of
edges of the temple grounds and such
and I think you know in the light of it
now 21st century like we you know I
think maybe even more than the biblical
writers perhaps are a little wise as to
what might be going on here I I Me Maybe
it's it's not coercive or something
possibly but you know when you got we
all know sort of people religious
leaders in power I just we you know
again the Bible doesn't say it but it's
just sort of it leaves you with
questions about why are these women
making themselves available I mean might
there be some you know well you're not
going to sacrifice here if you know like
so it's just this so this is a sort of
thing going on and the text seems to
elude that Eli right their father is
like not really doing much about
it so you've you've just kind of got
this um this kind of hot mess of a thing
um going
on and uh so in in essence I don't think
it's so much that God's holding out
right I think actually no God's wanting
speak which is why ultimately like just
keeps going down the ranks to like
finally the child like are you listening
I good here's someone I can talk to I'm
been trying to get through you know it's
Samy a little like
eight-year-old uh so that's really the
the picture I think is much more got
that kind of dysfunction God's speaking
but it's it's we who aren't listening
Theologian um Maggie Ross says this in
the first um verse we're told that
Vision sent from God a very few and far
between there's an echo here of the Book
of Proverbs which I love this connection
she draws I'd never thought of this
where Vision fails the people
perish i' always heard that kind of more
in like a I don't know like a leadershi
context where you know like the pastor's
got to come up with like a big exciting
Vision you know and get everyone pumps
for it or something um which is this is
sort of different it's like a a need to
hear from God you know where Vision
fails that people perish it isn't so
much that God is not sending Visions
it's rather that there are few people
who are willing to dispose themselves to
deceive them to know God's heart in
mind I think immediately of Jesus who
over and over would say uh if you have
ears then
hear if you have eyes then see and of
course he would be speaking to large
groups of people who they all had ears
and I you know but there's a way to hear
Without Really hearing there's a way to
see without
seeing and and I think that's kind of
what um what's being kind of getting
said here you might say the way I would
kind of sum it up to put it in my own
words I would say our challenge to hear
the whisper of the spirit it's not
rooted again in a lack of God speaking
it's it's about our own struggle to
become vessels of
receptivity and here I'll move the
through the generations we're like
radios stuck in between stations we're
like TVs with wonky antennas we're like
smartphones struggling to connect to
WiFi um in a in a in a world of noise in
other words we've lost the signal I grew
up um I was the TV generation I guess my
kids will be the smartphone generation
but I was TV we I remember um we had
this TV that would occasionally it would
just be like I it wasn't like these
fancy TVs now you know was there was
yeah it was like actual intend stuff and
it would lose like it would just go
crazy and what you had to do was you had
to walk up and you had to hit it did
anyone have a TV like this just it like
abusive just like pop you check nope B
and it would perfect it like f it would
work it's so stupid um like that's kind
of the image not that God needs to be
phys that's not my point not that part
but the right but the the losing the
signal it's like that's that's us it's
like we're there we're supposed to be
tuned in but um but we're
struggling and I I guess this kind of
brings up two questions for me a or
maybe even for you you might be
wondering what do you mean by signal
exactly you know like what does this
mean to be kind of vessels of
receptivity all these metaphors you know
like what are you talking about and um
second question might be why why have we
lost it so let me kind of answer those
um in order so first what do I mean by
signal um I'm thinking
here I mean it could be kind of very
dramatic like it is with Samuel like an
almost sounds like a kind of Audible
Voice kind of thing I think even um
um uh but yeah even verse 10 the Lord
came and stood there calling as at other
times Samuel Sam right so that's like oh
okay um and maybe that throws us off a
little bit because then we start to
either a expect that um or be never
experienced it and just sort of assume
like God just doesn't speak to me
doesn't connect with me I I'm just not
lucky like those Bible people you know
um I think I I want us to kind
of reimagine this so I'm thinking less
kind of dramatic signs and wonders I'm
I'm thinking though that can happen but
I'm thinking more along the lines of
like uh day in day out I preached on
this like eight weeks ago about the need
for silence and um our own need just to
begin to discern to hear have you ever
had those days where you're just like in
the spirit so to speak you're just like
flowing like the words you need are
given to you the act that the right
thing that you need to do you do it the
wrong thing that you should not say or
do you do not do you know it's just like
oh my gosh I'm like I'm you know it's
it's usually a day of like lower anxiety
um less fear maybe this is just me but
this is how it is for me like I'm not
I'm not uh because that's what distorts
the signal at least for me my anxiety my
fear I just get eaten up and I just
start reacting you know as opposed to a
kind
of
okay what's the next right thing
Lord what should I say what should I do
and then moving with that right that's
where I'm kind of thinking like those
days where you're like in the spirit
like that's what we're talking about you
know that's like that's when it's
working so to speak so okay so that's
the signal um why why have we lost it
why don't we live from this place why
are our days not kind of marked by this
kind of presence well let's return to
Eli's Sons um I think on the one hand we
probably are a little tempted to
distance ourselves you know um it's easy
to do that with Bible characters like
the ones the people that are like super
kind and loving we're like yeah that's
me you know and then all the others you
know are just like oh they're the worst
I'm so thank you Lord I'm not like them
you know all of a sudden we kind of
start sound like the Pharisees um so I
wonder that maybe instead of just seeing
them as such terrible people that we
would never you know become in any way
um what if we see them as kind of
symbols symbols of people who are like
called to a path like a form of life for
them was the priesthood maybe it's not
that for us you know but but they're
called to a way of
life but they are rejecting
it and they're they're chasing they're
they're losing themselves in a life of
distraction in their case it sounds like
addiction um
avoidance and foolishness of every
sort and and and what's happened it's
like they were called to a path that
they knew they're called to it but
they've wandered From the Path and it's
taking them places that maybe even after
a decade or two or three they're like oh
my God like how did I end up
here can anyone relate to being have you
ever been felt called to the path and
before you know you're like oh I am off
the path uh how how did I find myself in
this
place one example I keep coming back to
um is that I think it just the parallel
to those called the spiritual life is so
I just think so similar um is the
calling of an artist I think as kind of
modern people maybe we can relate to
this a little more so I really believe
like uh some of you have like this kind
of call this this artist thing in you
and you know like that's even if you
don't like do it fulltime or whatever
like you know you were called to be a
maker you're called to be a Creator and
there is a a form of life a way of being
there
and and there's certain things like in
essence you can't then reject that and
sort or sort of run from it and begin to
live a life of avoidance and addiction
and
distraction and still do your best
work right like that's just not how it
it that's not how it works like you you
start and so can you see I like that
analogy because it's not about God
punishing you you know what I mean like
oh I'm not going to speak to you no
that's is the whole idea God is always
speaking God's always think of the
artist I think God's always the spirit
is always speaking giving ideas giving
creativity it's just an endless Fountain
the question is how are we tuning into
it are we receiving like do we have a
good antenna so to speak you know and
this the thing with the artists like you
can't leave that path and still
expect for the spirit to to flow in the
same way I came across this delightful
um little YouTube short of an interview
with Bob Dylan I I need to find the
whole interview because I don't know the
beginning of this interview so it's just
I caught it you know mid Midstream um
but Dylan this is him he's kind of
reflecting we have kind of The Young and
the old Dylan there um so he's
reflecting um this is him when he's much
older reflecting on his life career his
create cre of work and so he says this
he said um well I used to I don't do
that anymore I don't know how I don't
know how I got to write those songs the
interviewer you can tell is somewhat
confused uh he says what do you mean you
don't know how I mean you're Bob Dylan
you did it you know and he says well
those early songs they were like almost
magically written and he just starts to
quote it off the top of his head says
Darkness at the break of noon Shadows
even the silver spoon a handmade blade a
child's balloon eclipes both the sun and
moon to understand you knew too soon
there is no sense in trying pointed
threats they Bluff with scorn suicide
remarks are torn from the Fool's Gold
mouthpiece the hollow horn plays wasted
words proves to warn that he not busy
being born is busy
dying I love this he says well just try
to sit down and write something like
that there's a to
it and uh I did
it well I did it at one
time and I don't want to judge Dylan I
don't know you know he doesn't say why
is it that he felt he kind of lost some
songwriting magic at some point you know
so I don't I don't totally know why but
I do know this as artists right artists
are called to a certain way of life and
you can't leave the path without certain
repercussions and if that's true for
artists how much more
true for you and me like the The
Community of Christ people called to the
spiritual
life uh I mean how much more true like
in the same way artists have that their
rhythms aren't we too called to certain
rhythms certain way ways of being uh
certain um practices of of prayer and
scripture and silence and and a certain
avoidance of some things you know I mean
an avoidance of like too much
distraction
crazy um busy
exhausted which I'm guilty of um as I'll
get to in just a moment um where it's
like what happens it's like we just lose
ourselves before we know we're like Eli
and Eli's Sons like we're Dylan just
like we've kind of lost the magic and
we're like What like where did I Stray
how did I end up here why am I not like
hearing God like I used to you know one
of the difficult lessons for me
personally has been those rhythms of
rest and
renewal oh I've had to learn this so the
hard way as a pastor I think um I don't
know like minat driven people I guess I
learned you know when you're young that
well the the way to be a success is to
work hard you know so uh that's what
they said to do so that's what I did you
just work real hard and
uh but I and and of course there's
something good in that I mean I agree
that part of adult scene is sort of you
know at times doing things you don't
feel like doing and you just need to do
it you know so that's that's fine but
there's a difference between that and
utterly
overriding my my body's
signals that
hey we're exhausted it's time to stop
and I'm like
no no because I don't want to be a
failure you know or whatever the the
thing but we can't I can't do that like
what I noticed was I got worse working
harder getting worse worse as a pastor
worse as a parent
worse as someone on the spiritual path
learning to
discern my I got like a radio station
you know I was like radio between
stations TV with wonky antenna I
just and there's something about
learning to come back you know so that's
what it is for me but my it's different
maybe for everyone you know um what is
it for you what are those things things
what are those ways where you know ah
this brings me to the spirit and we also
know those things like oh that's taking
me to Dark Places that's nope nope nope
that can you see what I love about that
is it's so different than like well you
just shouldn't do that that's just
Wicked you know and it sort of becomes a
guilt trippy think like this is this is
not about again God punishing this is
about us knowing like oh no no there's
things are life-giving and ways God
speaks and there's things that like tear
me down and so I'm not doing those
things
not because God's going to hate me God
loves me but because it's not good for
me
you this kind of brings me back to
Samuel I'll close with this um I don't
think it's a coincidence that in the
story it's the child who
hears that it's right while all the
adult the adults in the story
are struggling you know we've got Eli
with his conflict of
avoidance we've got Eli's sons
dysfunctioning all over
town
um and yet it's like the the adults are
exhausted and
distracted and addicted and avoidant but
who's the one who hears it's the child
and I love his response
speak your servant is
listening God that's beautiful so
attentive
so
simple speak your servant is
listening just ready to
receive oh
church that's all we have to do like it
really is that
simple speak your servant is listening
may we all recover the heart of Samuel
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit amen
so as we uh as we come to the table of
the Lord tonight as we take in the body
of Christ and the bread the blood of
Christ in the wine may we do it in that
Spirit attentive
listening pure-hearted
simple and may it then become a moment
where God speaks you sense that
connection that that
love so
um the way we're going to kind of
partake tonight is uh we'll just go row
by row so we'll start here at the front
and uh as each row kind of finishes the
next row can join here in the middle
aisle um we practice what's called an
Open Table meaning if you're here
tonight and you'd like to participate
then you just go for it you are welcome
to do that regardless of exact you know
denomination or your theology or
whatever um if you something in you
wants to connect with Christ then you
are welcome to uh come forward and
participate you should know the red is
wine um the white is grape juice and uh
finally you can just partake whenever
you'd like um immediately you could you
know return to your seed in partake
there just however you want to do but no
one will lead you through the exact you
know moment of of partaking so uh this
is the table not of the church but of
the Lord and it's made ready for those
who love him and for those who want to
love him more so come you who have much
faith and you have little you who have
been here often and you who have not
been here long you who have tried to
follow and you who have failed come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here come to the
[Music]
table
we
[Music]
am
all right if you'd like to stand and
join us for this last song U remain
seated if you'd like to but if you'd
like to stand and join
feel free we're going to close out our
time here in this space with a a very
familiar song hopefully um we've been
doing this a lot the past three to four
years and so uh join
[Music]
in let's go out on a on a high note
here sing together I I love
you I love you
Lord for you have delivered
me I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my my soul
from Death my feet from stumbling I will
walk in the land of the
[Music]
Liv sing that again from the top I love
you
I Love You
Lord you have Liv
me I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul
from Death my feet from
stumbling I will walk in the land of the
living I will bless you I Will Bless You
Lord For You Heard My Cry I reach out my
hand and you saved my life I will bless
you Lord for you heard my plead and the
god of Heaven turned it dear to me I
will bless you Lord for
unending love for your grace and mercy
down from Ab I Will Bless You Lord to
the very end I will call on you as long
as I may
live I Love You
Lord you have delivered
me I love you
Lord for you have delivered my soul
from my Fe from
stumbling will walk in the land of the
living my soul from my feet from
stumbling I will walk in the land of the
living
[Music]
um I know normally Marion would come
back up to close this out which she will
in a minute but we wanted to take a
moment there's always there's something
about um I think endings which are
really important you know it's easy to I
don't know sometimes we want to avoid
feelings you know and so we just try to
like well just move on just move on and
really it's not like anything is even
going to change you but actually like um
you know our time here at Pleasant
Valley like even though we will still be
able to like partner with them in a lot
of ways we can still come to Fourth of
July firework show out here and you know
like this we we're still in the same
Community we're not like leaving leaving
but there is something significant about
us um kind of moving on from this space
you know and so I um want to invite up
Reverend Denise um yall give her a hand
she comes
forward so um before I give her the mic
I wanted to just tell um say to her in
front of all of you how incredibly
grateful we are that yall have been so
much more than just a business
Arrangement where we will rent your
space and you will tolerate us you know
because we give you some a little money
too little by the way they've been very
gentle with us in the Years um but this
you all have been like um like really a
spiritual family to us and um we are so
grateful because when we started this
community we really were like kind of
spiritual little orphans sort of just
wandering out there and um and y'all
just took us in you said it's going to
be okay you know um just incredible so
we are are so so grateful um so thank
you
yeah maybe I was tuned in and maybe I
was listening um um I remember I was
down in Houston with our Administrative
Assistant who has um
metast metastatic cancer and she is
getting treatment down there and she's
been clear now for four years but we
were down um at MD Anderson and I was
waiting while she was getting treatment
and I saw an email pop
up and it was from
Maggie and she said we're a church that
has uh lost its home because we are have
decided to become an affirming church
and we're looking for a place to meet
and I
said huh and in that moment God said
answer now answer now I mean it was like
almost like he was saying Samuel but it
was
Denise and you know in the Bible every
time that God says someone's name twice
you better stand up and listen tune in
um but it just there was something that
said to me you need to answer now and I
think I did fairly quickly yeah oh you
called me on the phone I was in a denist
appointment and you were like I don't
know how long ago you sent that email
but I'm just now seeing it and I was
like I just sent it like a couple of
hours maybe
before I was just um I something in me
said that
um I wanted to be a part of this and um
I will tell you that from the moment you
all came here I loved you all and this
uh Church loved you we have prayed for
your growth and so even though I'm just
I've been crying all day um I am so
pleased I am so pleased God is doing
such great work and I hope you know that
you are loved you're loved by God you're
also so loved by me and this church and
you can always come home
again just know that that we are a place
that we want you to know you are welcome
anytime that
um we will continue to pray for you but
we will miss you so much and you better
well Brett's preaching for me next week
so I know he's
not and I think I'm preaching for you on
the 25th so so
but I just want you all to know that um
thank you so much for um helping my
congregation who when I first came to
this church might not have been as
welcoming but you all taught them what
it means to
love and that uh what it means that it's
it's okay that we don't all see eye to
eye that we're all not the same but we
all are one in Christ and this my
congregation has grown tremendous ly
because of the witness of your
congregation so thank you so much um and
don't be
[Applause]
strangers how do I follow that
up um just want to say thank you again
to Denise um I know that I'm not the the
only one that thinks that this has not
just been a building for us yeah this
has been so much more than that um it's
been lifechanging for a lot of us so we
very much appreciate your hospitality
over the years Denise um I want to thank
you all for joining us tonight as always
if you're new here uh we definitely want
to get to know you more um you know
learn a little bit about you so if you
feel comfortable come find me after
service Brett whoever or you can scan
this QR code or there's some little
cards in the foyer fill it out give us
uh your name so that we can reach out to
you and so that we can ask you how we
can be there for you and be praying for
you if you are in uh General need of any
prayers hugs high fives anything again
come find myself or anyone else and we'd
be happy to do that for you and show you
that love that you deserve here at the
table we are committed to um having a
Christ centered inclusive environment
and a lot of how we do that uh the key
component comes from us as a
congregation and are giving so if you
feel led to give I encourage you to scan
that QR code or you can also again find
that little card in the foyer and fill
it out that
way um always say it my personal
favorite going to lead us out with a h
benediction so you can stand if you'd
like to um you know in a posture of
receiving stay seated whatever you're
comfortable
with you are a child of God you are a
child of God this is true on your best
day and this is true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
it's yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy and
you are accepted just the way that you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these some
these gifts of UNC of unconditional love
and grace to everyone that you come in
contact with be blessed have a good week
we will see you next week at our new
location um again if you need this info
on the paper feel free to take one thank
you please sign the banner on your way
out in theil please please even if you
don't know their congregation doesn't
matter just leave your
name okay
fine where are the kids here we
[Music]
go let
me let me the
CL me that church mother in Church Clap
man
back
that
[Music]
but
ch
[Music]
churchy
if I can make the whole church clap but
Ain a clap in the heavens CL just a clap
clap
[Music]
Church
ch
stand let
me let me the chur CL
[Music]
[Applause]
that was